Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel I'm here in the woods of Alaska
and I am going to be working on an
awesome Bushcraft shelter we'll be
cooking some amazing food bringing the
family along and I'm also going to be
answering some of you guys questions
that I know I get a lot of come along
for the ride guys it's gonna be a good
video
[Music]
well that's Bear poo right there they're
starting to wake up
so many rabbit poops down there
well today is the day we're gonna put a
roof on this shelter and seal it up and
I must have a high degree of confidence
in my ability because I forgot to bring
the tarp and it's snowing today so
yeah we're gonna do this or we're gonna
have a really horrible night
[Applause]
foreign
to get a little hungry I think I might
make some lunch
I got some beautiful white bratwurst for
lunch
I love these white brats
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
well there we go that looks pretty tight
it's not going to be waterproof but
it'll keep a light drizzle off me and
definitely keep the snow out
well it's not perfect but I think we got
it buttoned up pretty good
all right
oh I gotta tell you what it's nice up
here so much of that fires heat is
coming up on this platform
toasty warm
we got the shelter done and I still have
a few hours before Sunset so I think I'm
gonna go do a little hunting I'd love to
shoot a grouse or a tarmigan but I think
snowshoe hares are the most likely
animal I am to run across there's just
sign everywhere these are old Snowshoe
hair poops you can see where the hairs
have been chewing on these branches
see that that's a p mark from a snowshoe
hair
there's more two marks
some old Fox prints right there
you see a pine squirrel's been eating
pine cones right there
well we got a good chance of seeing some
Pine squirrels too but I've eaten them
before they're not good
so the key with hunting Snowshoe hairs
is you just gotta go really slowly and
just look and look and look you're
looking for a White Rabbit in the middle
of the snow main way you spot them is
their little black nose or their black
eyes
uh check it out that looks like some
coyote prints
looks like I'm not the only one who
figured out there's rabbits here
there's some tracks right there there's
some tracks right there
you know I get a lot of people asking me
whether I carry a gun or any sort of
protection when I'm out in the woods and
the truth is I rarely do especially in
the wintertime there's really only two
situations that get me nervous about
animal encounters one is where you have
limited visibility and you can walk up
and surprise an animal and the other is
in campgrounds animals are used to
taking food from people are aggressive
and cause real problems well right now
all my food is sitting back at the
shelter unprotected and the odds of
something getting into it are really low
but if I was in a campground I would not
do that you really don't have to worry
too much about surprising anything in
these conditions every time I take a
step it makes a racket so loud every
animal can hear it really hard to sneak
up on anything in the wintertime
oh
I think it's time to make some dinner
all right you got a little potato there
this is a Tomahawk Steak and it is a
gorgeous one
questions
um
oh that is a good steak
oh my goodness this is so much food but
the good thing about winter camping The
food doesn't go bad
I'll just uh put that in the snow and
it'll be good for tomorrow
a little salt and butter on a baked
potato not bad at all
it's been one heck of a meal
all right for dessert I've got Ling hee
movie flavored gummy snacks from Hawaii
anything covered in linghi mui powder is
amazing
if you've never had lingi mui powder
it's uh really hard to describe but you
should go to Hawaii and try it out
that was an amazing meal
but I've got a belly full of delicious
food a warm fire and a cozy shelter so
it's not a bad day
the shelter on fire
go deal with that
okay
catching your shelter on fire is a major
issue all of this wood right here is dry
and warm and if a fire starts it spreads
pretty quick now if you're awake and
paying attention you can put it out
pretty quick but if I was asleep up here
when that happened I could be engulfed
in flames before I realize what was
going on and this stuff up here is
really dangerous if this stuff catches
on fire I am not going to be able to put
it out in time when I'm sleeping in
these shelters I'll often Let the Fire
go out or I'll keep it really small and
make sure it is far away from the walls
and in a shelter like this where it's a
little bit hard to get in and out of uh
I got to be extra careful so I'm
probably not going to sleep with the
fire on
it's not that cold tonight I don't need
it but in the meantime I'm just gonna
make sure the fire is a little bit
further away from the walls
well guys it's getting dark so I'm gonna
go ahead and make sure I've got enough
firewood for tonight and tomorrow
morning nothing worse than getting up in
the cold and then having to go out and
gather firewood
all right
well I am exhausted but it's not quite
my bedtime
so I'm going to turn on an audiobook I'm
gonna shell some peanuts and I will see
you guys in the morning
oh it's so cozy in my sleeping bag but I
have to use the bathroom so bad
I think I better get out get the fire
started
oh that fireworms this place up so
quickly it's nice
all right I think it's time to get some
breakfast made
foreign
[Music]
breakfast
we got some smoked pork gel bacon
homemade crumpets that had made a few
days ago Fried Tomato egg not bad at all
butter and crumpets is hard to be if you
never had them they're kind of like
thick pancakes really similar recipe to
pancakes
oh that was good well I think it's time
to start straightening up
foreign
but this is not the end of the video
first I want to go get my son and my
wife and bring him over and show him the
shelter but also I need to take the
shelter down so that's something else
I'm gonna do and I'm going to show you
too
the driving to the shelter
does it look nice
yeah we got a hot dog stick it looks
cooler in person actually it does you
like let me get the Caribou hides out
and you guys can hang out on the bed
while I get some lunch made
all right should I get a fire start get
some lunch made
yeah all right let's do it here mama let
me hand you the lunch there's some gummy
snacks in there
thank you oh yeah that's for you
yeah you don't get to do this very often
do you
oh this is fun to try it out you guys
like eating gummy snacks in the fort
here yeah we got some hot dog sticks
here
okay
my first all right yeah you like your
extra long hot dog stick I do this is
very convenient yeah there you go now
where you put your hot dog in the fire
tells a lot about you this is the foodie
the starving camper that I have ADHD the
four-year-old and then there's the sword
fighter
[Music]
you like that is that a good lunch
is the shelter warm
sitting on it's soft yeah no this is
pretty cozy I'm fine
I like how the heat comes up underneath
your bottom and warms your bottom up
yeah it is nice you good you're full
yeah all right I think it's time to tear
the shelter down
oh we gotta pull this all apart make
sure there's no paracord no trash all
right let's get to it all right
well there we go it's all taken down and
all that Woods ready to be chopped up
into firewood well babe did you enjoy it
I did
oh you're good you ready all right let's
go
well Liz this was fun I hope you guys
enjoyed watching this video if you want
to see more videos from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
Saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]